I think I'm recording now this is mike
arrington from TechCrunch actually
sitting next to a Robert Scoble has
taken one of the YouTube computers here
at Davos to uh oh so I'm supposed to
answer the question what's the question
what's what one thing do you think the
country's companies or individuals must
do to make the world a better place in
2008 citrus in the thousands of
responses I think now the YouTube team
that's here actually something getting a
little bit depressed listening too long
they're excited about the responses but
some of the stuff was depressing them
what's interesting about Davos is that
this you know there's 2,000 people here
and they're all talk about the same
thing I talk about poverty to talking
about global climate change those are
the big issues they talk about other
things as well economic growth in in in
less developed countries it's clear
though their needs me waiting to make
the conversation extend to UM a much
broader audience see millions of
thousands from its there is no
grassroots campaign today around around
global warming there's lots people care
about it but people are not marching on
Washington about it so to make that
happening after engage of a broader
audience and I actually think about wit
da blitz is doing here with uses is a
good start just to get lots of people to
say what they care about and what they
think should be done to make the world
about in place this is the first unit
did it so next year actually I think
we'll really see this probably explode
so being here for an hour 2009 to look
back see how much this is evolved and if
YouTube itself to become a platform for
grassroots efforts sort of a virtual
equivalent of marching on Washington so
that's all I'm saying for now I am gonna
have it I'm honored to be at Davos it's
great they're letting bloggers in I hope
that they let more in in the future
we've been trying to behave ourselves
and play by the rules and hopefully that
means for bloggers would be letting in
the picture